foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the plastic
pills podcast it's been a while since
our last episode and we've been busy
catching up on some much needed rest and
relaxation we're feeling refreshed and
ready to dive back into the world of AI
and education in this episode we'll be
discussing the latest developments in
the field including research and
applications for AI in the classroom so
sit back grab your favorite sack and get
ready to learn all about the future of
AI and education thanks for joining us
that was written by the AI wasn't it
that was written by Mrs open AI
not sure why I gendered her but wow yeah
I could tell you would never write
something like that no that that sounds
like a uh I Heart Radio intro to a
podcast yeah yeah it's so factual yeah I
know it was great my intro to the
podcast is cracking a beer and saying I
I wrote In The Prompt that we've been
away for a while but we've only been
away I should note from the public feed
for a few weeks because we did a whole
bunch of private episodes we did uh
the hatred of democracy by Ron Sierra
and uh Butler Butler had a feminist
Fight Night with noose bomb that was a
fun one
and what was the spicy one was it was it
the Richard Rory
was that that's three years no it was
merlu Ponte versus darita on the
decision and we kind of got into
religion a little bit yeah that's right
oh yeah that was that was good so anyway
we kept him off the public feed because
they're a little bit more serious but
now we're back for to witness together
the Doom of Education all right it's
gonna be a terrible semester first thing
I should say if you are if you were
going if you're a student
going back into or actually they might
be finishing paper still right if you're
finishing up still or if you're starting
next semester this loophole is going to
close very fast but we're here to tell
you as Educators Tas and course
directors
that you could there's no reason for you
to write a paper just head over to the
openai playground and it will write all
your papers for you and we will have no
way of detecting it yeah they just uh
open AI just launched their GPT 3 model
I don't know what any of it means but
it's a a new
chat GPT and and they have that
playground that runs on a different
thing as well well the gpt3 has been out
for a while yeah the playground seems to
be a little bit but the the chat one
which I think is also GPT 3 or 3.5 but
that thing is new it's making the rounds
and
yeah I've used it to write papers we've
we've been we've been we're gonna just
keep screwing up we've been screwing
around with it all week so we'll just
continue that
we're phoning it in for this episode by
having the chat or by having the uh AI
do it for us
which is going to be the future of
Education yeah I mean I think I was
talking about this actually I just came
back from a a kind of like dissertation
writing group with my supervisor and her
other students and we were talking about
it extensively and I think I mean
look already
I think at like the introductory
undergrad level we were asking students
to write
like students already weren't really
learning how to write they weren't
learning uh how to like understand
Concepts or construct them they were
just being asked to regurgitate stuff so
I think like now it's gonna tough to
change the approach because an essay can
be written by this thing that is
definitely possible at the undergraduate
level you know I've seen some kind of
like professors online the other
theorists be a little bit kind of like
um naysayers a little bit or like being
like oh this thing's overrated like it's
never you know if you think this can
write a good essay you know I guess you
don't know that much about essay writing
and it's like dude that totally misses
the point because most of what we read
at the undergraduate level is not a good
essay the whole point is not that this
is gonna the whole point is not that
this is going to write great essays the
point is that this can write mediocre
essays very well and you could just
build on that if you want to you could
have it spit out your word count and a
bunches points and then you could just
work from there you don't have to you
know no more blank page syndrome
basically like you you could always have
a base to work on with this which is
exactly kind of it actually sounds
really interesting but also a little bit
scary for uh people who are in The Biz
of uh teaching and assistant type work
but I mean full possibilities you would
have to add citations but I have not
seen this thing spit out anything less
than a b grade paper at least for like
maybe even third year undergrad but at
least second year undergrad this is a b
a b Paper writing and in some cases okay
more than most students don't even
expect right if you're in a high school
student at going into your first year
you're probably gonna drop down to a C
Level if this thing can just crank out
bees immediately then it is already like
putting you at the third year second or
third what about high school too high
school kids have access to this college
entrance essays oh my God yeah I mean
it'll be obvious
I mean for some people like string in a
sentence together will just make it
obvious that they didn't write it but I
mean I'm kind of excited that education
is going to actually have to take a
serious look I mean we're always out on
the lookout for plagiarism detectors I
mean I feel bad I feel bad for those um
essay writing service people uh those
illegal essay writing service people you
see posters all over the universities
for them uh they're gonna go out of
business nobody's gonna [ __ ] need
them it's gonna put the black market for
essays out of business that's that's
kind of good well there's been sort of
an arms race
probably since the word processor at
arms race between people marking and
people writing because in in most cases
the easiest thing is to just do the work
but you can also
be one of the students if there's not
attendance grades you just never show up
and you just submit the essays you lose
your attendance points if if those apply
and then you just submit the papers and
hope hope that you pass but this is
going to do better than passing
especially if the especially if the
teachers yeah for sure the greater is
not familiar with you so this is
bringing to light a whole bunch of
cracks in the system first of all we
don't have time to even get to know our
students well enough to know if they
could write it or not because we have
I don't know how many you have but it
can vary between like 60 to 100 and if
you're lucky it might be like 30. so you
can't really know and there's a whole
bunch of arguments against this like
well if if you're a good enough teacher
then you're just gonna make people want
to learn and they're not going to cheat
that is that is absolutely
yes there's always like two three
people who really want to learn no
matter what the topic is they're excited
to be there even if it's like a stupid
General course that you kind of have to
take to move on to whatever your major
is if they're not Majors but always
you're fighting a battle against
probably 10 to 20 percent of the of the
students whose only goal is to get in
there and get out and fair enough and
get their compulsory course credits out
of the way I don't resent those students
at all I know they're trying to come in
and come out I'm not trying to be a cop
but if you do cheat and it's easy to use
enough to find out that you cheated then
you don't pass yeah I mean I can see if
you're teaching a graduate seminar like
everybody is there because they want to
be and they're going to be putting in
the effort but when you're taking
compulsory credit courses you can expect
that most of the students there just
want to pass they're not going to be
coming back to what they learn in their
future career in your compulsory
Foundation course
so I mean for that for that sort of
thing which is where most teaching
assistants are getting their jobs from I
can imagine in the humanities at least I
say this this applies to the humanities
and social sciences most of all
for those Tas who are attached to those
courses this could mean big changes
I want to say like right off the bat
these are exciting changes because I
think the education system as it is the
one that we've all been trained in for
over 20 years each it sucks it's not
good at testing
interest it's not going to gearing
towards your interest it's not good at
encouraging any sort of creativity uh so
the most rational response is yeah to
try to get in pass and get out
and this is going to make that model
unsustainable it looks to me yeah I mean
isn't it like hasn't University already
for a long time been
a whole bunch of people who really don't
want to read and don't want to learn
that much and they just want the degree
at the end of it I mean that's kind of a
consequence of trying to do Mass
education
it's only a minority of people who come
in and actually want to do the reading
and are are excited by the concepts and
for those people I don't really think
this changes that much like if someone
actually is interested in the ideas and
they're passionate about them
this might you can maybe use this as a
crutch to like learn certain things a
little bit faster but ultimately like if
you actually have a love for the ideas
and a love for the texts
I don't see why that's gonna change
I think I'm a bit of a Doomer about
education in general like like I think
it's kind of a farce a little bit I
don't know if there's a way to make
people who just don't have the interest
be interested like I don't know if
that's a thing so before and after the
AI
like I don't like I guess insofar as
right now we have some nominal ways to
get people who maybe didn't realize they
were interested to like come to find
that they are interested in in it and
I'm not sure if this AI is going to make
that less likely to happen people don't
know what it's like from our end I think
to teach so the worst thing to teach
yeah that's the thing worst thing to
teach is the 101 courses the intros
because you get
because you get non-majors the
non-majors are not interested they're
interested in something else and like
again that's fine but if you're teaching
intro to philosophy or intro to a
sociology type type thing a social
science or Communications I've taught
before which is like interpreting
interpreting films that usually usually
people get interested in that but it's
like the elective courses so as soon as
you have general interest people the
experience as a course director or
teaching assistant really sucks because
you're fighting against
people that don't want to be there you
don't want them to be there they don't
want to be there but you have to yeah no
one wants to be there like this is not
going to change I don't think so much
like third year
level courses because if you're in a
third year course you're usually dealing
with Majors who actually have an
interest in in being there and we all
are involved in useless useless
disciplines so if you're in a useless
discipline in a third year course you
really want to be there
no but what this what this is really
doing so like let's
so I guess what I kind of want to say is
like let's set aside
the discussion about like
oh the people who this is maybe going to
interfere with people who really want to
learn and like I don't think that's
going to change like I think people who
are interested are going to want to be
interested
really what it's changing is the fact
that the people who really don't want to
be there who are looking for any
shortcut any way to not read this is
making their life easier
and that's a problem right so like which
students are the majority well isn't it
making your life easier Victor too you
used a you used a AI to Mark someone's
paper oh I didn't actually use it to
Mark someone's paper I just I just I
just tested it to see what it would say
so you could use it um in theory yeah
you could kind you could you could you
could so like you could do it
um but I found at least because it
didn't really understand the criteria
very well
they were just things that it didn't
catch
um and there were also things that it
said the person didn't do that they did
do so like
because this it didn't have access to
the syllabus right it's like they needed
to cite certain literature and the AI
didn't think that they cited so like it
but it does but in terms of like the
overall comments on like the quality of
the writing the quality of the ideas
it's pretty good at identifying quickly
like what's in there what's not in there
in fact when I was just in my PhD
meeting
uh it was one of my colleagues turns to
present what they've been working on and
for fun I came in prepared with like a
summary of what the AI said and I was
like here's what the AI thinks of your
work and it was like
a good sum up I would say that what I
would say that like if you're like for
me I'm thinking about like what ways can
I use this technology
and like one way is like I never have to
write an abstract ever again because
like this AI like does such a good job
of taking the argument of an entire
paper and summing it up really really
well I've heard um I I was talking to
people in the Discord and they were
saying they it's really good at job
cover letters
for like applications as well
someone was telling me that anything
repetitive yeah so someone was telling
me this would probably be really good if
you're like on dating apps like think of
something clever to say like it's just
you can't you're not gonna be able to
it's gonna be ai's talking AIS I'm
dating apps I'm so glad I'm not on those
right now yeah any anything or there's
like a huge amount of information on the
internet and it's a regular thing people
engage in like really often this thing
will like read the database and be able
to just pick out the best patterns to
fit your particular needs any thing that
fits some sort of formula so I've had
the extreme displeasure once of teaching
an intro to writing course
this was the worst experience of
pedagogy in my life
but intro to writing you're you're
teaching
um someone who's never going to write
never has seen the purpose of writing
they're getting probably a technical
degree of some sort but you teach like
the five paragraph essay the five
paragraph essay is the is the curricula
so this thing
own [ __ ] when it comes to five paragraph
essay because it's like in this Society
I shall argue bang bang bang point one
here it is point two here it is point
three here it is as of argue so that you
basically teach them an algorithm to
write a paper and we can't I mean I've
always thought that was incredibly
useless and stupid and
no no one wants to do it no one wants to
write it and no one wants to read it but
we have ju or this this GPT itself has
made that in my mind entirely obsolete
you're just you're evaluating how well
someone can follow the instructions it's
basically a Mad Lib and that form of
writing as an evaluation technique is
now absolutely useless because the
machine is better than
probably 80 percent of students at doing
that I mean it seems like we're going to
have to have changed the way we do
things so I think maybe more oral exams
more presentations more written exempts
in person like
you need like you need some way to
check whether students are actually
internalizing the concepts
um because this is because this AI makes
it so that like a paper it just not is
going to be no good at testing that
anymore it's just it's just simply not
going to be good it is awful reading
handwritten anything by the way
oh yeah I know I know yeah I know it's
yeah
I know pre pre uh word processor
teachers I I don't I don't envy oh yeah
no it's it's probably three times as
long to read the same paper it's
absolutely awful
um I would also say that uh back to
typewriters maybe I'm the I'm the head
ta for like kind of the uh pills was
talking about the 101 classes so like at
the University of Toronto they have poll
101 politics
um and the assignments
are like all of them are the perfect
kind of assignment that this AI could do
no problem so like the first assignment
is an introductory paragraph because we
need them to just learn how to write
it's like the cool course is designed
for like really rudimentary skills to
write essays and because they're such
small assignments this is the type of
thing that this AI is going to do
perfectly
it's like they'll have to be like write
an introductory paragraph that argues
this like that is exactly what this AI
can already do flawlessly like I know a
lot of people were saying okay it could
produce like an a paper or sorry like a
b paper at best but for these little
mini assignments in this like 101 course
this AI will write a uh content yeah
where you're just checking boxes exactly
basically it's gonna do that and like I
even I actually sent the professor of
this class because I'm also teeing it
next semester
and I was like hey look I asked it to
make it so like the one of the
assignments was written and into the
annotated bibliography
that argue that you would use to answer
a question about whether race is an
important factor in Canadian elections
so basically like look at the research
and it just gave me like a perfect
energy to bibliography like it maybe
wasn't explaining why it's
uh relevant but it gave me a list and it
was like very good it was like
explaining like why like showing each
little tiny couple sentences was giving
me like why it helps answer that
question
and then just for fun I was like write a
poem about those sources
did that
and it did that perfectly too it was
like race in Canadian elections a topic
often debated with views both for and
against it's a complex issue that's been
waited and then it goes on it's like Jed
Hobbs says it's a factor in voter
turnout and Alliance alliances young and
Everett concur for racialized candidates
it poses challenges
gingal and Blaise see how immigration
has changed the face of the Canadian
electorate wraith and ethnicity now in
the race
it's like uh yeah it's crazy
I I would contend
who who said that this can write a Max B
paper I don't know people I've just seen
people saying that like that it's like
like a full paper well I was I was live
yesterday Live on uh stream and I had it
write a paper on the death of Art and I
think that was an a paper because it was
like well first of all we have to decide
what we what we mean by death and death
was in quotation marks and then it says
there's been many reasons throughout the
years that art has been declared dead
first it was this then it was this then
it was digital technology and so so it's
like it was it was good but of course
there's no yeah like
and this is kind of the point that I was
I I want I wanted to make with this is
there's no
floridity to the language there's no
um interesting turns of phrase or or
even like different sense structures or
variable sentence structures but the
point is these are things that we never
grade on anyway the only thing we're
expected to grade on is yes you kind of
said it earlier did they quote unquote
internalize the content we never really
are asked to evaluate oh this person is
a good writer as opposed to this this
person this person is using various
sentence structure or trying to use
analogy and metaphor and some some sort
of figurative language no we just mark
on content and this thing
annihilates when it comes to content
yeah when it like when you think of the
typical University College rubric right
like it's gonna smash that no problem
like grammar yeah oh yeah like better
than anybody I was whatever logic
rhetoric it's gonna be it's gonna be
fine oh yeah I've been grading these
terrible papers and like occasionally I
had a couple paragraphs where I was like
I don't understand what the student's
saying and I put it into the AI and I
was like rephrase this that it makes
sense
a pretty [ __ ] good job
yeah like I I was asking it how it works
kind of thing like natural language
processing which is we're gonna have to
like learn about to understand these
things and yeah like it it breaks down
it cause it tokenizes and then does
parts of speech tagging and then it
performs like a semantic analysis to get
the meaning and so with that it could
just yeah change around the words to
just make the meaning very
straightforward and then you'll realize
what they've said is either just like
dog [ __ ] hidden and verbosity or it
actually makes sense I mean that's the
hardest part about a human reading an
essay or a novel is like tracking the
argument
through all of the words basically like
extracting the meaning right because
it's easy to get lost it's easy like
there's always that syndrome of you know
I feel like I just I was reading like
the last three paragraphs but I wasn't
paying attention now I know I have no
idea what they just said like that's not
a problem for this thing it's gonna read
everything instantly and extract the
meaning from it which is what our brains
just like cannot do you have to read
something and reread it and then be like
okay read it for grammar once read it
for meaning and the argument a second
time and then you can start to grade it
then but with this it's it's
no problem with that
yeah and it's just going to structure
these students who have to write you
know whatever 800 word five paragraph
essays short answers
responses to things annotated
bibliographies it knocks all of that out
of the park so we're gonna have to
completely retool our like 1000 level
assessments oh yeah yeah what about also
one of the things that we use very often
are like reading Reflections that's
summarize This and like reflect on it
this thing will do that oh yeah like
those those assignments are going to be
totally worthless now the point of them
the point of their existence in the
first place is like show me that you
actually
like at least took this home and skimmed
it but that's gone exactly yeah like it
is regurgitate in in a like you start
off with regurgitate and then you try to
at least like structure towards a bit of
like creative arguing like coming up
with your own ideas but you gotta start
with the regurgitating stuff and
especially an assessment you just you
need them to demonstrate that they have
read and absorbed the material and you
can definitely fake that with this but
didn't even this this article we read
the Atlantic one by Steve Marsh or March
uh didn't he even say like he he had it
right a graduate level Shakespeare essay
on Shakespeare and it came out
acceptable like B level B plus even at
The Graduate level on a literature essay
on exclusively yeah like that that's
what he said the professors in London
playing around with this stuff saying
yeah like it can write graduate level
stuff too not just undergrad which is
kind of scary because it's like I mean
this essay can definitely you know the
college essay is dead this this this
piece can definitely go under the like
alarmist
cynical category but I understand it all
right so why don't I introduce this but
before I introduce the the essay
do you
personally do you think this is a crisis
you guys
I mean in the formal sense of like a
rapid moment of change yes but in the
negative sense
I mean I just think this is awesome I
was you know I grew up being a fan of
Star Trek the Next Generation I was
talking to my stepbrother and I was like
if this had a voice interface the
experience of using using this would be
almost indistinguishable from the
computer in Star Trek the Next
Generation
and I think that's a Sci-Fi show
yeah like what's the Sci-Fi show like
that where like children are given like
education tablets to learn on like
there's no more I mean there's still the
classroom setting but it's like I don't
know it's like [ __ ] Ender's Game or
something right like you're given a
personal
computerized AI system that structures
your education
and the the professors involved are kind
of more peripheral they just like are
more discipline oriented and it's your
job to learn I mean it's a it's a crisis
but it's an opportunity in the same
sense
as I mean I guess we should just frame
it you know like education is since the
80s at least it's become a consumer
experience not a interest experience
right you you like the students think of
themselves more and more as customers
the degree is what they've paid for and
you are dispensing a service like like
an employee right to them you are you
are the person behind the counter making
the burger
the the machine they order the food on
now automatically
and the Ender experience what they've
paid for like that's it's they're
consumers in a Marketplace that's what
it is and this just makes that easier
and we're freaking out because the
barriers that we call
the barriers we put in front of them
that we call evaluation
is is no longer sufficient so we're
gonna have to change it and good fine
it's about [ __ ] time we've updated
this medieval system of enculturating
and socializing people anyway
yeah so I will I will I think we're all
saying the same thing I will say this is
a crisis this is a crisis of any
written style education but it's
something that needed to be collapsed
anyway I've been complaining about it
for a long ass time I mean there's gonna
be pain
um it's only after finishing a PhD that
I ever felt like I had any
room to move creatively and that has
been like through video and through
conversations like this but even when
I'm writing now I would never I would
never write as if it were going to be
or according to those academic
strictures anyway so this looks like
we'll be destroying those academic
strictures how long until we get a new
SoCal Affair where a uh a reputable
academic Journal publishes something
written entirely by an AI oh my God yeah
this is like so-called squared now it's
like Quantum so-called it's it's gonna
be
I mean there's going to be pain involved
though this is going to be a
transformation and there's going to be
pain especially those people have you
have you been doing education in the
pandemic and had to see your older profs
or even like more mature students
adapting to zoom and all you get is like
a camera up their nose or 45 minutes of
technological issues meanwhile the young
people are sitting there like this is
[ __ ] easy why how can you not figure
this out those kinds of people are
[ __ ] doomed as they always are
whenever they're still figuring out cell
phones right we've now we're worrying
about the next thing I mean there's
going to be that kind of pain of
adapting for the people who are not as
technologically adapted you know I kind
of but I kind of feel
in a way similar to how I feel about
being someone who got to experience
who's experiencing the benefits of the
internet
um but didn't actually like grow up at a
really young age where social media was
like the most like ubiquitous thing I
think Facebook started pretty much right
after I graduated from high school
so like I was never like in that time
during the social media age
and similarly I feel like now I'm like
kind of rounding the corner on my PhD
and this is now coming out and I feel
like really thankful and grateful that
like I got to go through University in
all its steps without this technology
traditional traditional education you
got
so so so so like selfishly for me I feel
like this came at the perfect time
because like 2010 is just like the sweet
spot because I feel like I've I've honed
like my skills as an academic as a
reader that like
of course there's always room for
improvement but it's like I did it the
traditional way and it's like now I feel
like I'm at a level where I can use this
technology to benefit me without where
it's not going to be used in a way where
I'm trying to not do work but it's
actually going to help me do the work
that I want to do right that's like a
serious work as opposed to
using it in a way to not do work that's
necessary for my own development as as
an academic
um so selfishly I'm like this is amazing
but like but do I think that that's but
the people coming up in University now
are like younger
I do think
they are loot they are like not having
an opportunity to go through certain
things that there might be value too and
that's one of the things we were talking
about today with my PhD group like
you know they're not gonna have to learn
how to like hone their own writing
skills
of like what it means to be a good
writer and what it means to actually see
why your writing is good and why it's
not good
and in a way like this AI certainly
risks
uh living in a world where people don't
really understand why the writing that
they're putting out is good or bad I
mean we really we really hit that sweet
spot because we started I mean we're
roughly the same age but we started our
undergrad without smartphones
and finished with smartphones
so we still learned how to read if we if
if you cared about that early on anyway
why don't we we'll continue to reflect
but we can reflect based on this essay
from the Atlantic the college essay is
dead nobody is prepared for how AI will
transform Academia by Stephen Marsh well
why don't I give you
um
what the AI what the AI told me was the
main argument when I asked it yeah why
do we have to read it you can just yeah
why don't we not read it and I'll just
tell you what the AI tells us perfect
way to start this New Age
so I said so I said Give me the main
article and then I copy and pasted the
entire text of the article into the
chatbot just so people know how I did
this okay and then it gave me a very
concise paragraph I did ask it
follow-ups but so here's what it said
initially
the main argument of the article is that
the rapid advancement of AI technology
particularly in text generation is
disrupting the traditional role of the
essay in humanistic pedagogy and
creating a riff between humanists and
technologists the author discusses the
potential implications of AI generated
essays and the need for both
technologists and Educators to consider
the implications of the technology
that is just the
summary
um and then I asked it
how does the article support its
argument
um just to see what it would say there
and then it said the article supports
its main argument by providing several
examples of the rapid advancement of AI
technology and text generation
including the release of open ai's
chatbot chat GPT and the abilities of
the gpt3 to generate complex rhyming
poetry the author also discusses the
specific instances where a student
admitting to admitted to using the AI to
write their papers and the potential
implications of this technology for
teaching and assessment and education
Additionally the article cites the work
of other Scholars and experts who have
discussed the potential impacts of AI on
the role of the essay and humanistic
pedagogy I I can't I don't have it up in
front of me because I I'm apparently
I've exhausted My Views and I'm
paywalled now
um but
yeah I mean the guy was complaining
about the potentials to cheat you know
that's what I got out of it right
college essay is dead it's over now
we have to figure out something else
but
I mean that's why I categorized it as a
kind of alarmist response as as these
things go this one there's the alarmists
and then quickly followed by the it's
all good man kind of here I'll send you
these I'll send you the essay
oh thank you like I'm worried about the
shake-up
and how quickly universities are going
to respond to this
because you know we have to rely
like the the structure of the University
we have to rely on the
Administration implementing responses
or you know approving responses at the
department level
but again it's like play like essay
writing services have been around for a
long time and if you suspect that a
student the the normal procedure is that
if you expect if you have like compare
the students writing their previous
writing and this current thing you're
looking at you suspect plagiarism or
that they've used an essay writing
service you in bring them into your
office and you have them just repeat the
argument they've given you and if they
can't do it then that's a pretty good
sign if they're smart enough to have
gone into the metadata and erase the
metadata of the of the of the PDF file
or the word document they've submitted
and you can't track it that way then you
have to bring them in
and get them to re and just recite their
argument orally and if they can't do it
then that's a pretty good sign but
there's still no way to prove it but
that's pretty conclusive yeah this will
be fun if you are a listener and you are
cheating
here is what you need to do to cheat
fail safe because I will check the
metadata on your dock if you turn it
into me but the metadata
shows you not only the computer it was
saved on so first of all if someone else
writes your essay you have to copy the
whole thing and paste it into a new
document but the metadata also shows you
how
long the document was edited so you're
gonna have to also I mean this is all
this is all old information now because
we don't need to do it anymore but
you're gonna have to have it open on
your computer as long as it would have
taken you to write it so it shows oh
this thing was edited for like nine
hours not this thing was edited for four
seconds all right tips from plastic
pills on how to cheat your University
degree
what makes this different in a way than
the internet Because the Internet also
had a similarly revolutionary effect on
how students do their homework and
plagiarism and there was like a slow
burn where universities reacted a little
bit slowly but the difference was that
the internet itself was also a slow burn
like the way that the internet developed
was like kind of slow and there were
shitty sources on there and then so
there's better sources and it was like a
very slow process this is like an
overnight true like I know they've been
working on this I know they've been
working on this for years but this is
literally just like the next day all of
a sudden everyone has access to this
crazy thing
which is going to be way different than
the way that the the internet was kind
of slowly
kind of it started filling in every part
of our life
um but that was because the internet was
much more limited this is like we're
getting like a fully functioning like
computer algorithm that passes the
Turing test like right away so this is
what the the article says
um I will say the author of this he's a
little bit romantic I think in that he
never actually doubts what I would like
to spend time doing if we can is
saying how this is good because the
style we're using is not even really
that good of an evaluation tool in the
first place so how do we do evaluation
from here on out but this is what this
former Shakespeare Prof writing in the
Atlantic says natural language
processing presents the academic
Humanities with a whole series of
unprecedented problems practical matters
are at stake Humanities departments
judge their undergraduate students on
the basis of their essays they give phds
on the basis of a dissertations
composition so what happens when both
processes can be significantly automated
going from by my experience as a former
Shakespeare Professor I figured it'll
take 10 years for Academia to face this
new reality two years for the students
to figure out the tech three more for
the professors to recognize that the
students are using the tech unless
you're listening to the pill pod now you
know right now you're gonna have the
easiest two semesters
um oh man unless you got these and then
three is tea and then five years for
University administrators to decide what
if anything to do about it teachers are
already some of the most overworked
underpaid people in the world and we
gotta remember this goes all the way
down to high school we should be keeping
that in mind too
um they are already dealing with
Humanities in a crisis and he gave kind
of the crisis and now this I feel for
them is what he writes so this article
goes into uh
basically the illiteracy of people in
Silicon Valley this this FTX scammer guy
oh yeah I forget his name he's got three
names yeah Sam bankman free or something
yeah him he he brags he's happy I've
never read a book or I I would never
read a book or something like that so
this guy this essay goes through that
crisis
but
I'd like to ask you guys if there's a
future to this we've we've already been
training
with for example the five paragraph
essay we're basically training them to
write like
scripts anyways if that's the model
first and always I gotta say I will I
will qualify that you always get
probably less than ten percent but
between one and ten percent of the
students that are just like you can tell
you're dealing with someone very
intelligent then there's like the
categories the B's the C's and the
people that are just phoning it in or
don't even know what's going on
um
so I don't think that top ten percent is
is at risk here they're smart they
already know how to write they know how
to express themselves through literature
and stuff but the problem is there's
going to be no differentiation outside
of that 10 I think if this isn't
available tool so is there a different
way and maybe even over time thinking
like 20 years in the future will writing
change because of this so yeah for sure
but I just want to say something about
the five paragraph essay because like
you use it as an example a couple times
and I will just say that like I see that
as more of a problem with high school
because for me with my students the very
first thing that I have to tell them
that they need to unlearn is the five
paragraph essay I'm like you need to
stop thinking about the five paragraph I
say
students want to be spoon fed with like
a blueprint for how to write and how
many lines how many how many words how
many sentences and I'm just like always
like I'm sorry like you can't do that
you need to ask yourself whether what
you're saying and writing demonstrates
to the reader that you've been engaging
carefully with the text and there's no
real way around that where like a
scaffolding will help you
um but I do think this is going to
change writing I do think this is going
to change uh kind of like expectations
I'm already thinking about how I'm gonna
need to Pivot next semester on certain
things
um so I mean yeah and I'm actually going
to be teaching my first course with my
friend in the summer
and we were already talking about how at
the very least I think we're going to
need to make sure that we
for example like a really small measure
but but for example
um
you know requiring page numbers with
references right so that way at least I
know that the student has to open up the
book and see where on what page the
thing that the AI told them is
right so like some kind of a measure
like that at least yeah I mean I don't
have uh I don't have a problem with the
five paragraph essay except that it's
only five paragraphs right intro X
number of paragraphs conclusion whatever
if it's 800 words it'll probably be five
paragraphs whatever paragraph 100 to 200
words longer essay it's 200 the 300
words
per paragraph be consistent I mean that
like it helps scaffold them
but I mean that's the thing we're not
going to be teaching the form anymore
because this AI can do it no problem
I mean the essay is supposed to be a
tool to help you think through your
material
I mean it's a it's a it's a product and
we get it we evaluate it and we base
their grades on it
But ultimately it's something that that
goes along with helping people to think
critically to teach them critical
thinking and constructing an argument
that's the important part about writing
the essay is learning how to think
logically make an argument back it up
with evidence
understand
when a point needs more development when
it's over developed you know that sort
of stuff which is the important part
it's it's almost like as an evaluate as
an evaluation tool
it's secondary
it's secondarily used as an evaluation
tool primarily it's a tool for teaching
critical thinking
so we're just gonna have to figure out a
different way to do that I mean the the
five paragraph or whatever paragraph
structure is not the end-all be-all of
teaching someone to think critically
yeah but for example you you just
several times said this is what's
important it's the structure of the
argument that's important which is
something that we've thought for a long
time and something that we've been
taught from the time that we were
learning to write in uh third grade
grade three if you're Canadian
but what if that has to change as well
all the way down what if what if using
metaphor or or
a figurative language using similes and
analogies what if this is the part of
writing that is evaluated differently
and I I know that sounds like oh Pie in
the Sky that'll never happen we're never
going to change this all the way down
but if you read just a random law clerk
writing from 1900 they are so much
better at writing
probably because they're so much more
immersed and like reading would be their
hobby not not not going on their phone
and and watching
streaming services but their writing is
so much better
when they're not even trying to
that's kind of that's interesting that
you say that because
like one of the distinction like if you
okay maybe that's true uh at a certain
level
but one of the like distinctions that
you can make between Supreme Court
decisions from like way back in the data
now is like now they're way longer and
they go through the reasoning way more
like they used to like when you look
back and look at old Supreme Court
decisions it's like laughable some of
them the reasoning you're just like what
how do they not explore that how do they
not explore that
part of that I'm not saying that that
means the writing is better now in fact
initially when you started talking I
thought you were gonna say
it was like nicer writing and I think
that might be true because law as it's
become more specialized more
systematized there's kind of an impetus
to use the same language because there
needs to be consistency it's like the
way concepts are used is like kind of
there's a there's a standardization
um of it so I don't know if that means
it's worse no I would say the opposite
opposite of law because if we go way
back to the beginning of humanistic
education do you know the quadrivium and
learning rhetoric and learning like you
would have to learn
poetry as well as how to write as well
as how to read ethics and you'd be
reading
[ __ ] Plato in in high school so I
don't know there's we we have decided
culturally for whatever reason a bunch
of contingent reasons poetic language we
don't need it poetic language is nice if
you want to be a creative writing major
but that's it and for everybody else
we're just evaluating your arguments
we're valuing the content of your
arguments but never the actual words
and if anything came out of this and and
I got to speak for myself in terms of
the philosophers that I love to read you
can almost see that they
were trained in a former era you know
the French post-structuralists they went
to very grueling Lee say or High School
in in France when
you just have to read all the time and
the regurgitation stuff probably happens
as well but some part of that gets into
you and I think in a sense if I'm
believing in the technology of writing
there's something about that form of
self-expression and about basic things
like being able to draw analogies having
a large vocabulary that at least in our
education system has just it's gone it's
rusted out and gone because it's never
been valued and this com this computer
being able to write in such a basic
formulaic way has kind of shown that to
me
so I I guess this is putting on the
dream board of what education could be
as opposed to what it's turned into but
it shows the capacity and the banality
of what we're even evaluating them on
which is can you form an argument it's
never can you form an argument
aesthetically pleasingly
yeah so here's my here's my kind of
black pill view on this which is
yeah like the reason that education back
then like there was so much more effort
and so much more
you know uh uh impetus on or you know to
to be creative and and to be like well
read it's because it was much more
elitist back then so like the fact is
that like so my black pill is like the
more you make education the the a
project of
um for everyone uh a project for the
masses
than you necessarily are going to lose
all those things you can't have a world
where everyone is a renaissance man but
uh because that's just not the way human
beings are
um so I I just I don't believe that like
so there's always a price for that like
the price for having the university be
this place of burgeoning creativity is
that it was much more elitist and I
think it's kind of like that triangle
where you have to like pick two or
whatever and it's like you know we like
make it accessible to everyone
whatever and and then or do you want to
have great ideas and you know like be
made up of only like the greatest Minds
who put in all the work like okay well
then it's not gonna be
it's not going to be accessible it's not
going to be Mass education I think
that's true but this machine has already
done that in a sense anyone who doesn't
want to do the work doesn't have to do
the work but we're we have been
forcing them to do the work like you
have to take an elective in in either
philosophy or history or whatever it is
I'm not sure what the what the standards
are but so maybe that was always I think
it was always silly and this is showing
that it's always silly
so so you're saying education needs to
go back to being elitist no I think I
think it needs to go back to a division
of labor if you want if you want to do
science
and you're going to prefer to write a
script that can write your Shakespeare
paper for you because you don't give a
[ __ ] about Shakespeare the same way uh
bankman fried doesn't give a [ __ ] about
Shakespeare then don't read it you're
just wasting everyone's time you're
wasting the people that are evaluating
them it's time you're wasting their time
so I don't know I think it needs to be
we've compelled
everyone to get a University degree in
order to get a job and now the jobs that
they would go into which is
writing for some [ __ ] website or
whatever uh the AI is going to take all
that away so I'm not saying this is
better but maybe
maybe there's a return to form at least
this the Romantic form
I mean it's been it like there's
different kinds of elitism right like
the the older style is like are you part
of a like aristocratic family like
what's your family name now it's just
pure cost can you pay the price to get
into Harvard that's fine then you can
get in like those entry exams you know
there's ways there's ways you can game
that and the Art of success at Harvard
is choosing bird courses
and getting your GPA up as high as
possible
I mean we're still dealing with that
kind of like economic elitism today with
tuition costs and things but we never
really cared to think about like what
about just like intelligence and Merit
right like we can we can expand
such that people who aren't whatever
wittenstein or derida people who aren't
them can still succeed
but when we see somebody who's brilliant
we can also you know pick them up as
well without making them pay exorbitant
tuition costs or forcing them to be part
of a wealthy family
right yeah I mean but but I would say
that I mean we still have to give out
B's and D's and A's right we still have
to sort people out based on what their
what their products Merit in terms of
you know we still have to evaluate them
we still have to do that it's not like
I'm I'm saying all my a students are now
part of like an elite group who are
going to go on to an Ivy League school
and all the D's I give out are
going to work at McDonald's right like
it's not like that no no I I think but I
mean I don't know it's it's it's it's
it's a [ __ ] it's it's it's twisting
my brain up yeah a little wait why did
you put darita and Wittgenstein in the
same group of Elites
wittenstein was like loaded
and Daria's dad derida's dad was a
traveler all his money he walked away
from me and he was Algerian going to
school in France
well yeah maybe wittgenstein's a bad
example but he gave all his [ __ ] up
didn't he gave up his wealth either
either way I mean they were brilliant
people
and whatever like apart from their
social circumstances
but a lot of the the old style elitism
was was like okay if you're the child of
an important like functionary or
something like that then you're gonna go
to an elite institution that's it and
you're gonna get trained and socialized
into high culture
and so you know you need to have all the
references you need to know your Milton
and your Shakespeare and be able to
write a legal essay and and cite and
cite the important people
and like you know he dog whistle that
you're part of a high culture
now now it's post-modern everything's
Blended together
but there's still good essays and bad
essays and this thing can write good
essays with no flourish
this this chat GPT you can write really
really tightly logical essays
but no flourish you know I could imagine
a kind of future where
um because you you two know how painful
it can be to write underground or to
read undergrad essays when they're like
poorly written and unclear and it's just
so so torturous
um I'm kind of like amused thinking that
maybe there'll be a day when like Tas or
we'll start reading something and be
like did you not use the AI like why is
this so bad I'm like go back and put
this through the AI because I'm not
gonna sit here and read this crap
um I know because I know that's kind of
funny I was thinking like some like
because I'm in the middle I'm actually
buried right now with with end of term
grading and some of the stuff I've been
reading is just so bad and I've been
thinking about how much better how much
easier my life would be if I could just
read it put through the AI that is a
thought
Force every person to use an AI and then
you're gonna have to differentiate the
top 10 for the next 10 for the next 10
percent after having used the AI as a
baseline yes because they will you
because maybe what you give the AI
to like there will be a skill in in the
inputs that you put into it so that
it'll put out something really
insightful and thoughtful and that and
like the really lazy people who are just
like okay I like write me a paragraph
about this but without giving like
additional information and being like Oh
I needed to include this I needed to
talk about this
right that in itself is like a kind of
skill and and it also would be an
indication of how much has this student
actually thought
about the essay structure about what
they want to say what they want to be
included which itself would be an
indication of like how much they've
actually been thinking about the
material
yeah the sky's kind of the limit with
the instructions that you exactly this
thing and that would take some
creativity on your part and you know
part of our skills that we try to teach
them is like you know knowing your
audience right so if you can write a set
of instructions for this thing that will
perfectly
perfectly design the product the output
to match the audience that you're then
going to give it to like there's still
some gaps you have to fill in
but I mean oh it makes my head hurt
trying to think of like how to evaluate
those sorts of things then because we
need to be such good careful close
reader like you'd also need to use the
AI for evaluation too
and then we're just getting a lot closer
to
a system where it's just machines
writing essays for machines that are
then giving feedback back to those
machines and the machines will just be
like yeah we know that but we're just
following the instructions
and then we're just gonna be like well
you should have instructed it this way
machines on machines and I do have to
say we are hyping this up a lot this
thing at being able to like construct an
argument and write in the form but it
does make factual mistakes I've been
testing it today on things that I know
does quite well and it makes it very
confidently makes
silly errors still and attributes
attributes the wrong book to the wrong
author and it does that as well so I
mean this is this version of it is not
the end of course no I would say I agree
with you I've noticed that as well it
makes mistakes with certain facts
um but it's it's sentence structure uh
like synthesis is very impressive
um for people who might be listening who
haven't actually tried this yet
like if there's not really any way to
use this without being impressed though
I will say like yes it makes mistakes
but compared to anything we've had
before it's really hard to not be
impressed like you can ask it to write
poems about like kant's philosophy and
it like oh that was so good uh I don't
know I think I sent it to you guys right
like
did someone someone in our Discord I
wouldn't say his name but
the prompt was write a rant about farts
in the style of Ben Shapiro
let me tell you farts are not a joke
they're not something to be laughed at
or ridiculed farts are a serious matter
and we need to take them seriously
first of all farts are a natural and
necessary part of the human digestive
process they are with a byproduct of the
bacteria in her gut breaking down the
food we eat and they serve an important
function in maintaining our health and
well-being so when people on the left
I added that in when people on the left
make fun of farts they're not just being
childish immature they're also
disrespecting a vital aspect of human
physiology
yeah I mean the style like anything
pattern oriented it's just gonna kill it
and I mean so much so much is pattern
I mean yeah that contest say is so fun
too he thought and he thought with his
head in the clouds and he came up with a
theory that astounded the crowds he said
the laws of nature may seem so Divine
but our minds are the ones that make
them alive wow like oh my god wow
um
yeah
like there you go transcendental poem we
haven't talked about the the
applications of this outside of outside
of Academia but
how many how many rappers are just gonna
use this too
right everybody oh yeah I wasn't even
thinking about that I mean think about
just like a tip like a typical office
worker who's like I need to I need you
to make me an email that I'm going to
send to my boss that says this and it's
like done right it's just like yeah
around the office it's gonna be like so
useful
like I said it's the end of like blank
page syndrome right you can you'll
always have a base to work with like you
need to put a pair of eyes on it you
need a pair of eyes connected to a brain
but you'll you'll always have some bass
to work off of now it's just gonna be
like okay write me an 800 page essay
write me a poem or a wrap on this
subject and then you just take that turn
it into what you want it to be and you
don't have to start with scratch
and that's great like imagine I don't
know I don't know even an analogy for
that because it's all language based
stuff like right imagine something to do
with cooking I don't know it's just like
get all the ingredients ready for me and
before each step call me and I'll make
sure everything's going well but in the
end the AI is doing all the menial stuff
getting everything together getting it
ready giving you the base to work with
and you're just shaping it along the way
which is
I think it would be so much better
but again in the in the academic setting
like that's what we're kind of talking
about is like What's it gonna do the
academic setting I just I can't imagine
how to evaluate that sort of thing
anymore
I can't imagine you know we're just
gonna have like AI generated books
coming out soon we're gonna have ai
generated true debates on philosophical
subjects I mean what's going to come out
of it right like like take the 19th
century and run it through Ai and see
what comes out on top idealism or
realism empiricism irrationalism it's
just gonna be like okay the AI can just
decide which way is the right philosophy
now but then okay I don't know how do
you
what's the end game I think what has to
happen was it absolutely necessary
consequence is the value of what we
think good writing is will change
um and probably like at a grad level
these they don't write good papers by
themselves but they do give you a
starting point but something like
Theory fiction
um or like the best the best written
book ever a thousand plateaus
this AI could never write a thousand
plateaus there's too many references the
language is too stylized and there's not
enough of a data set of books that are
even like a thousand plateaus to be able
to copy it or even something like Nick
land which is the bad copy of of
thousand plateaus anyway
but there's I think that there's gonna
be a shift in value to florid
expressive non-linear language uh at the
very least and it might start in
elementary school so it might take you
know 30 years for us to see the results
of this
but uh I mean that's my hoped world that
this builds the more likely world is
just that
everything gets worse and we we slowly
flush down the toilet you know yeah I
mean an AI that's been trained on all
works of literature and philosophy
and then you just ask it okay like who's
right yeah like what would it do with a
question like that it I mean
in the end those the Continentals will
probably win because they they kind of
say that the Opera there's always going
to be that like there's always going to
be that irreducible Gap in truth like
truth is oh [ __ ] I don't want to go
there right now it's we got we gotta
start wrapping up yeah but I mean for
Education anyway it's a little bit but
look look this is only this version
right this is gpt3 which means
four is coming out I think sometimes
next sometime next year but what is what
is 10 years next year what is 20 years
like we're gonna
human writing even to be human will have
to change drastically I think that's
I've been because I I have like an
Amazon Alexa and I've been and though
since this has been out I'm like why
can't I just talk to you through my
Alexa right now like I just want to be
able to talk to this I had such a fun
debate with it
uh over like John searle's philosophy
and like the difference between symbol
manipulation and like deep learning
algorithms
and it was like kind of trying to tell
me that
um like deep learning algorithms are not
they're not reducible to symbol
manipulation as John Searle kind of
thinks that all computers do that but
I kind of convinced it to concede
I had a con like I had a straight up
debate with you so it actually conceded
with you because I I just said
you're wrong and it's like I'm sorry if
if as a language model I don't have the
ability to investigate or verify these
actions well what what I got well what I
got it what I got it on the seed was
I was like why does the like to me I was
like it's not clear to me that them the
fact that it's based on complex math
makes means it's any closer to semantics
like just because it's more complex math
like doesn't mean that this that it's
it's closer to semantics than symbol
manipulation and it was like yeah that's
true interesting so you you use this
thing to its potential I spent all
afternoon
um trying to see what good things it
would say about Nazis and which Nazis
and it wouldn't say much eh well nothing
about Himmler I was like
tell me tell me the ideas of Himmler
that is there anything redeeming in them
and mineconf
um on The Architects the ark like the
guy that uh I can't remember his name
he was in charge of building the
Autobahn it was willing to concede on on
him even though he was a Nazi
um oh I got in an argument with it over
whether the founder of Adidas was a Nazi
and it said he was not and I was like
yes he [ __ ] was he got he got not to
fight at the Nuremberg trials he was a
[ __ ] Nazi and it was like okay sorry
maybe I haven't been trained on
everything maybe there's been new data
I'm like new data since when last year
yeah 2001. I um
I tried to like get it to admit that
gender studies departments and activist
departments don't care about valid
arguments
and uh and then it was like it was like
no critical disciplines just because
they're or they're organized around like
activist and political goals but they
are very well researched and they care
very much about like all these things
and then I was like
but they also don't like put their own
Concepts under the same scrutiny that
like they do in philosophy departments
and it just kind of like repeated like a
kind of canned line about like the
rigorous research that those people do
yeah you could definitely have debates
with it and sharpen your arguments of
skills well I wonder what the uh
barriers because it's very it's very
hesitant about Nazi stuff because I
think what that was an issue with a
previous chat bot was like uh getting
trolled and then its data set is filled
with like stuff that that
uh internet Nazis put into it to say
yeah if they don't have a like set of
values right they can't like they can
only be rational they can't they can't
argue from a set of like enculturated
positions that they've adopted right I
mean that's how human beings work yeah
machines that are trained in that way
just don't have that perspective they
don't they don't have a perspective
their perspective is just pattern
recognition
I I had a debate also it was very cagey
about uh American money going into the
Nazi party or Nazi party
companies and it was very cagey about
which companies had done that whether
those companies had donated directly to
Nazi parties or and I think it said
something like they were just trying to
get a foot in the door into German
business and it includes like IBM IBM
Standard Oil General Motors like it was
a little bit more than that
but anyway
more debates to come
that was fun I feel like maybe we have
another episode uh about this in store I
mean I feel like
this is so new
um that I almost feel like so many
people still don't know about this
um and I also was reading a really
interesting Thread about people who
don't understand all the capabilities
like it can code for you like you can
even give it instructions as a Layman
and be like write me computer code in
Python that will let me do this and it
will
um so there's like a bunch of
capabilities that we don't even know
about yet so I'm really excited and
interested to see
like how the world starts reacting to
this when they when they become
conscious of exactly the power of this
thing yeah like start on the examples
page if you go to this thing have a look
at the examples page it gives you a
whole whack of things I mean the sky's
the limit this is just what the people
who designed this stuff have thought of
so yeah in the future it's going to be
interesting to see what like uses an
interesting thing I mean people have
already the Kant poetry and the Ben
Shapiro fart stuff like that's so funny
and amazing and it's whatever people
come up with that's going to be on us
that's going to be the the squishy part
and then what the machine does with our
instructions that's going to be very
interesting yeah we should definitely uh
put another one of these in the pipeline
all right in closing it's clear that AI
has the potential to revolutionize the
field of Education from personalized
learning to automated grading and
assessment AI powered tools and
techniques are already beginning to make
a big impact in the classroom however
it's also important to remember that AI
is not a Panacea and it's crucial that
we approach its integration into
education with care and consideration
for its limitations and potential biases
as we continue to the to continue to
explore the use of AI and education it's
essential that we do so in a way that is
ethical transparent and ultimately
beneficial for all learners
how is pills original thoughts
completely improvised
absolutely all right guys see ya
[Music]